you may notice for some types like email
there's some basic validation
but it doesn't really understand
if you want to do better client-side
validation though html5 supports that
too there's also a pattern attribute on
the input element that you can use to
validate on the client side
the pattern element takes a regular
expression as expressed by the
javascript regex syntax regex is a topic
in itself so if you're not familiar with
it you'll have to look it up for example
let's presume i want to only allow us
numbers with area code prefixes so an 11
digit number
i can put in a regular expression for
this and now when i try to input a
telephone number
and then submit
it pops up an error message that says i
have to match the requested format
that error message by the way is the
element's title so you can customize it
too
and now i get my custom error message
normally of course i'm not going to want
such a simplistic pattern i'll probably
want something more like this string
which says i want a three-digit number
possibly preceded by brackets and then
optionally a space or a period or a dash
and then another three digits and then
the same space or period or dash and
then another four digits
now
this gives some options for how i enter
telephone numbers
but i can just say
and it'll accept that